theater palooza much like what street  theaters do today is searching for a  unification for the laws governing  gravity and the laws governing  electromagnetism what Oscar Klein did to  it he saw problems with calooza's  original model he realized that if the  dimension of electromagnetism The Fifth  Dimension were supremely compactified  into a microscopic sufficiently small  space then you could get around the  problem of are not observing them and  then you could do all the operations all  the differential equations that are done  in general relativity effectively and  that would pop out a field theory for  electromagnetism and you would get  equations of Maxwell out but you needed  to do what was called compactification  compactification is still Central to our  understanding of string theory and  perhaps to some reconciliation of the  so-called Grand unification of  electromagnetism with the strong and  weak nuclear forces